a surprise wedding Bristol Palin marries  her ex  et can exclusively confirm Sarah Palin's  daughter Bristol has reunited with her  ex Dakota Meyer and they even said I do  look at this photo both of them wearing  their wedding rings they tied the knot  and are now on their honeymoon the  couple tells ET quote life is full of  ups and downs but in the end you'll end  up where you're supposed to be Bristol  and Dakota have definitely seen some ups  and downs the couple got engaged in  March 2015 and they were supposed to  marry that May but they called things  off June 2015  Bristol announced she was pregnant and  in December she gave birth to sailor  grace her daughter with Dakota now these  two are focused on being a family they  also tell us quote with the love and  support of our family we know we can get  through anything